as we have been doing on numerous
occasions in recent days because of
something we didn't know
anything about six days ago that has
nevertheless become the biggest story in
the nfl the desean watson saga we now
have
13 lawsuits that have been filed against
the texans quarterback for allegations
of misconduct occurring
during massages 13 with
nine at least more under consideration
based upon what attorney tony busby
had to say at a press conference on
friday now i've been candid about
my concerns regarding the way that busby
is handling himself
that's my opinion doesn't change the
fact that these individuals
may have claims that have merit and
ultimately
any of them some of them all of them
shireen
may be able to prove in a court of law
either in civil court
or criminal court that there was
misconduct on the part of desean watson
regardless of anything that tony busby
has said or done
and sims and i were talking about this
today
with each passing allegation
it becomes harder and harder to come to
the conclusion
that this is all one big
misunderstanding or fabrication or
embellishment
with that many people involved the more
people involved the harder it is to
maintain a conspiracy like this
and make it something where everyone is
lying about desean watson so
he has rights they have rights it all
goes forward and with each additional
case it gets more complicated shireen
and it has to be more concerning for the
folks at the league office
well and you know what else makes it
harder mike with each passing case is to
make them go away
right because you're not just talking
about one agreement or two agreements
now we're talking 13 agreements with
possibly more to come
i've had trouble with the last two weeks
keeping up with two things
one is the number of free agents and
trades that the texans have made since
free agency began
and the other is these cases against
desean watson literally you can't keep
up before another one is filed we were
at 12 just what a couple hours ago
i look up and the 13th had been filed so
they just keep coming
my question is this mike i've been
around a lot of nfl players i've talked
to a lot of
nfl players they all get massages
and most of them get daily massages this
is not unusual okay
this usually happens but i've never
heard
i've never had a player tell me that
they have
more than one masseuse they use one
masseuse
all the time it's a regular and it's a
regular part of the routine at the same
time
off season in season whatever
they they do it at the same time with
the same person in the same place
and many times it's male a mel masseuse
and i had not even considered that
until these cases started coming so i
guess my big question would be
why so many and i know that i
read where it possibly because of covid
was using ins
that doesn't even make any sense to me
to me you have one masseuse who's going
to be with you
at all times mike if you're an nfl
player and can afford to do this
yeah especially if there's some sort of
an excuse premised on the pandemic that
would be all the more reason
to not have a revolving door of massage
therapists and
and that was based on a report that
emerged from tmz over the weekend
i don't know who leaked that i don't
know if this was part of the broader pr
strategy
for desean watson to get tmz on his side
by giving them some sort of a nugget but
that didn't move the needle in his
direction the reaction that i saw to
that was
so what and it's kind of nonsensical
that the pandemic is being cited as an
excuse for having a different massage
therapist apparently every single day
and if look what i said this today
regardless of my concerns about tony
busby and
some disingenuous comments he's made
about not knowing hal or cal or whatever
his name is that was his comment from
friday about not knowing
cal mcnair which we both agree shireen
was a little ludicrous
to it not being about the money when
it's clearly about the money the whole
system is premised on the money
um regardless of any of that
he's winning in the court of public
opinion because he's unchallenged
at some point you have to have something
more than the tweet that desean watson
posted last tuesday night
that for most people made them aware of
the problem in the first place
there has to be something more than that
if you have something
that is a persuasive and compelling
defense and the longer the time goes by
it doesn't matter what happens in court
with any of these cases you've got it
locked in to the minds of the people out
there who are hearing these things
that this guy is at fault nothing
prevents the average person from coming
to their own conclusion
as to whether or not they think he's at
fault they're never going to be privy to
all the facts of what happened they're
going to make their own conclusion and
the average person who's been paying
attention to this
and is hearing this is far more likely
to conclude he's in the wrong than he's
in the right
because his side's done nothing to shine
a light
on whatever his explanation would be
other than this
this report from over the weekend from
tmz so rusty harden better get his butt
to work
if he wants to try to turn this around
in the court of public opinion shireen
yeah mike i think he's already lost the
pr battle this has gone
far too long before his side has said
anything
and we're still missing that and with
these cases building at some point the
nfl right they care about pr
this looks worse and worse and worse by
the day and
at some point the nfl is going to step
in and say
all right we're putting you on the
commissioner's exempt list or whatever
they're going to do i realize it's the
off season
but from a pr standpoint the nfl's
losing in this battle
the houston texans are losing in this
battle and desean watson
certainly is losing in this battle look
rusty harden is fantastic
he's had adrian peterson he's had roger
clinton he's had a ton of guys
well he's had a ton of guys that he's
that he's right gotten out of
bad situations um he got roger clemens
into a bad situation i don't want to
relitigate something for more than 10
years ago but the defamation lawsuit
that roger clemens filed against his
former trainer
created a bad kind of jackpot for roger
clemens
other than that i have no concerns about
rusty harden but but his record is not
unblemished in high
profile cases let me just interject that
okay most cases he's handled a lot of
these cases
that he's handled a lot of these cases
he
he is familiar with the situation that
desean watson is in
at this point and he knows how to get
him out of that but i don't know what
their side is doing at this point
i don't know when deshawn watson hired
him how this has gone since then but
it's just getting worse by the day for
deshaun watson
and shereen at some point you got to
write the check to some sort of a pr
firm some sort of a crisis management
firm and this is where
the texans become relevant not for what
they may have done
that would amount to collusion with tony
buzz b and i explained today the
collusion could be as simple as tony
busby giving them a heads up and making
sure they're okay with him proceeding
with these matters and the texans saying
sure go for it he's been a pain in our
butt
we don't care we're not going to help
him beyond what they did or didn't do
in any communications they may have had
with busby the question is what are they
doing to work directly with
deshaun watson and is he accepting any
of that now
their pr function i don't even know
who's in charge given the termination of
amy palchuk during the season but
there's there is no discernible
pr effort on desean watson's behalf and
i don't know that that's rusty harden's
baileywick
anyway he's a lawyer now there's a
certain amount of pr that every lawyer
does but at a certain point you need a
skilled professional
who can handle something like this and
come up with a strategy
aimed at pushing back against the stuff
that tony busby has done
to make the average person who's been
paying attention this likely to think
something bad is going on here that's a
problem and with each passing minute
it's getting worse not better for
deshawn watson and
and i don't know whether or not shireen
they think they've got some silver
bullet that's going to turn this thing
around
but with 13 cases filed it it would have
to be one gigantic silver bullet to turn
this thing around
yeah i'd have to be video or something
right maybe they need to contact tony
busby about pr
mike because he he's won this court of
appeals right here
with in public court because he's been
terrific at the
at the pr and like you said we can argue
about the way he's handled this
but he's come out and he's talked and
he's tweeted and he's done all those
things so that the public is
seeing his side and his client's side
not the other side and if they have
something they need to come out and say
what they have and how they think this
thing will go away he didn't do it
whatever
whatever it is that they have that
silver bullet they need to do it and do
it soon mike
here's the other thing that strikes me
is odd from the perspective of someone
who practiced law and whenever there
is a a company or an individual
who allegedly has engaged in misconduct
and wrongdoing
the other lawyers in the community don't
stand down
and let one lawyer handle all the cases
they start to get involved they start to
investigate claims
they start to solicit claims in ways
that are permissible
under the rules of attorney professional
conduct or
or that aren't permissible as the case
may be that's one thing that
is odd to me here shireen the legal
profession the civil law
practice is for profit and it's premised
on
finding good cases against people who
have money and representing those
individuals
because there's three legs on the stool
as they explained it to me in law school
liability damages and someone who can
pay
and if you're missing one of the three
you're wasting your time
when you have someone who has resources
when you have someone
who has engaged in apparent misconduct
when you have someone who's misconduct
would be sufficiently shocking if proven
to result in a significant award for
mental anguish and other related damages
there should be more attorneys
than tony busby swarming around this
case
that's what is kind of strange to me
with each additional case
why is it only him there are surely
other attorneys in houston
who represent individuals in cases like
this
where are they because it is highly
competitive
highly competitive and and as i said on
friday when i was expressing my opinions
about tony busby's handling of this
at some point it is in the best interest
of one or more of the individuals
to have someone else handling these
cases because buzzby becomes too much
the center piece the focus of the
litigation but you know what sharing at
this point with 13 and counting
i don't even think it matters anymore
the raw numbers are at the
point where that is the story there are
too many
for the average person of reasonable
mind to look at this and not say
something stinks here and the chances of
the things stinking being on the
plaintiff side of the
ledger are getting smaller and smaller
all the time
mike you've been on both sides of this
you've you've obviously been in law
and you obviously know pr really really
well
if you're rusty harden how do you advise
your client at this point what do you
tell him to say or what do you come out
and say i tell him you should have
settled the first case when you had the
chance that's what i tell him because
that's what should have happened see
you need to be sure you've got somebody
who will take the advice you give and
one of my concerns is that
perhaps desean watson has been getting
advice that he's been refusing to take i
wouldn't work with
a client i don't care how much they're
paying me by the hour i wouldn't work
with a client who doesn't listen to me
my life's hard enough
without my clients who aren't listening
to me at this point though
i i would i would want to get in a room
with desean watson i possibly would want
to do a lie detector test
i'd want to know for myself is he guilty
of this
or not and if he's guilty it goes one
way if he's not
it goes another way and even though
polygraph machines aren't admissible in
a court of law they get used all the
time for all sorts of other things
and before i would spend my time and put
my reputation time my reputation to a
potential
predator i want to know damn well that
the person that i'm representing is
innocent so i would consider
having him submit to a polygraph if he
doesn't do it and find another lawyer
if he submits and he passes then we're
going to come up with a strategy
that is premised on trying to prove that
each and every one of these cases
is incorrect is mistaken is whatever uh
would be consistent with
him passing a polygraph test that's how
bad it is at this point
that's what i would personally do and
what that means is i probably would end
up
not taking the case because desean
watson would justifiably be indignant
at my request but i need to know that i
can believe the person
who's accused of so many instances of
misconduct
before i can go forward representing his
or her interest to the best of my
abilities so
i think that's what i would do you know
we started off this whole thing this
whole offseason with deshawn watson
wants to be traded he has a no trade
clause he'll get to dictate where he
goes
we're that's out the window too now mike
if he gets traded i don't know that he's
going to have a say in this
you know if if it eventually happens
then i i think
personally it's it's going to be paused
for now because
an nfl team wanting to trade for deshawn
watson is going to want to know what is
the nfl going to do
is he guilty of these there are a lot of
questions in this that you want answered
before you can
commit uh to what you're going to have
to commit to get to sean watson now
you can try to get a lowball offer but
if you're the texans you're not
accepting that at this point you're
waiting this out to see what happens
long term to go get him but there may
only be in the end i know what we
read over there's still five teams that
have interest in deshaun watson whatever
um or six but i you know i just think
his
options may be limited at this point it
may be one or two teams and me
he may have to accept that mike if he
eventually wants to be trading i do
think the texans
want to trade him now it's now it's just
a question of
when is that going to happen how is this
thing going to play out
sharing i think the analysis for the
texans at some point
will be we can't trade him
do we run the risk of keeping him on the
roster
and having him land on the commissioner
exempt list for all of the 2021 season
and in turn having to pay his full 10
plus million dollar
salary the great irony of all this in
less than three months
it may have shifted from watson wanting
nothing to do with the texans to the
texans wanting nothing to do with him
because if he shows up and if he's put
on the commissioner exempt list and
that's the device that's available
wide discretion for the commissioner pr
driven
if the kitchen gets too hot we got to
get the player out of it
we got to get the player off the field
we can't have the player in our games
being the subject of the perfunctory
mention that he's facing
13 sexual assault lawsuits and who knows
what the number would be by the time
september rolls around
so the texans analysis soon may be
do we cut this guy to avoid having to
pay him
10 million dollars if he's on the
commissioner exempt list for all of the
2021 season that's a judgment call
that somebody in texas is going to have
to make and
uh that that i think is coming that that
question
is coming it's going to be relevant for
the texans sooner rather than later
and i don't think anybody's going to
trade for him for now because you'd have
to you'd have to
frankly if i'm if i'm gonna trade for
him i i want the polygraph
i i i don't i you know it's probably not
legal
it's probably i remember i remember i
think mike shanahan
used a polygraph allegedly at one point
and i researched it under the cba
and it wasn't permissible but i think
that's the only way i'd be comfortable
doing business with desean watson at
this point
the only way that i would know is if i
know he can pass a polygraph
and tell me that he didn't do these
things that he's accused of otherwise
he's radioactive as far as i'm concerned
at this point uh the
the cloud is too thick right now over
deshaun watson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports